well when you're not in Big Sky how do  you cuz we just moved here how do you  like wind down here do you like to sweat  oh I like hiking if that's where you're  going no okay no this is if you're going  like spinning no not spinning you lay on  a table I'm in it's like an urban yeah  it's an urban so at Lodge you lay on a  table they wrap you like a burrito it  heats up they put headphones on you can  watch Amazon Hulu Netflix where we bring  you water it's the most toxins listen to  music and your heart rate goes up and  you burn calories laying there watching  TV I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this